author and columnist mark Stein joins us
hey Mark how are you hey I'm doing great
good see right it's been way too long
where do you stand on this boycott mania
well I think as chadwick was saying
they're doing this to make an example to
say that they take seriously the idea of
the deplorable so there are 60 million
people who voted for Donald Trump but
none of them matter and so if you are
prepared to put your neck out and hold a
fundraiser for Donald Trump in the
Hamptons you can't do that you can't be
one of the beautiful people you can't go
to any of the fashionable post Oscar
parties you can't be at the Broadway
first nights you cannot you can be a one
of those 60 million deplorable somewhere
out of sight but if you're a billionaire
and you and you're someone who should be
a member of the liberal elite and you
step out of that little box they're
going to destroy you to teach other
members of the elite you don't go
anywhere near Donald Trump are we still
pretending as if we don't get Donald
Trump he's been in the public eye for
decades he's been president out for
three years who've been running for two
and we know what happens it's not a
matter who you are the color your skin
or your gender are you attacking him
Elijah Cummings attacked his homeland
security secretary the president
attacked Elijah Cummings not because
he's black it doesn't mean he's racist
though the the squad came after
president Trump he went back not because
they're women
not because they're minorities because
they attacked him we know this
combination don't we yeah and
realistically Donald Trump is a New York
businessman and if you if you're there
on Fifth Avenue doing business you're
doing business with people of every skin
color every conceivable orientation
every conceivable type of non-binary
whatever you want to call it but as
Tucker was saying I think just a couple
of nights ago they use race and identity
politics the left us as a cover for
class and actually elite versus
deplorable ziz actually how they say it
all right I know you wish Tucker was
here you keep referring back to him he
fishing with his son you're doing great
Brian don't get demoralized you got it
there's a really strange movie coming
out next month Universal is releasing a
new film it's called the hunt the movies
heroes are several so called deplorable
z' from red states who have to fight
back after several rich liberals kidnap
them and try to murder them for sport
mark I love the pod what could possibly
be wrong with it well you know I will
say this I get bored by x-men 37 in
which cardboard man baffles franchise
girl up in the sky and rips a hole in
the space-time continuum so I actually I
actually approve of making films telling
stories about the way we live now we
live in an increasingly fractious 50/50
nation and if you're a playwright if
you're a novelist if you're a filmmaker
why wouldn't you want to address that
the interesting thing to me is how they
treat this and again it's the same
condescension we've just seen that the
essentially it's elites who decide
they're going to hunt deplorable 'he's
because they've seen their tweets
identifying themselves as pro-life right
anti-abortion and it is actually the
liberal Twitter storm fantasy taken to
the next level on Twitter they just
destroy your career get you fired close
down your restaurant but but but this so
called SATA actually wants to take it to
the next level right and make it
actually and take the cold civil war and
make it a hot symbol well okay so you're
happy it's not a Marvel movie or a Star
Wars 29 but I will say this they pull
the promos for it but not the movie next
another Hollywood story for you because
I know you love the elite actress
Rosanna Arquette gets a lot of trophies
and she just made a bizarre apology for
her skin colour in a tweet yesterday
let's go to it she says this I am sorry
I was born white and privileged it
disgusts me and I feel so much shame
mark your witness yeah
again this gets fake gets back to I
think that class thing we have an issue
here with rosanna arquette who's lived
the most privileged life in one of the
most luxurious niche societies in
Hollywood that has ever existed on the
planet she doesn't mean this she does
she does not mean this at all and this
idea of taking virtue signaling where
kirsten gillibrand did this at one of
the debates she was all yes I'm a white
woman of privilege - meanwhile you have
someone like Cory Booker who's been to
Harvard Oxford and Yale Law School the
the three best universities on the
planet pretending he's like some homie
from the hood this visit this identity
politics virtue signaling is now
departing from any conceivable reality
it's a it's a shame we've gotten to this
I think most people can see through it
we're not looking at the color of
people's skin it really the content of
their character and I'd rather not be
dragged into it but it keeps popping up
and it's all over these debates coming
up again in September well mark we've
hit you with a lot and you're just back
from your sabbatical I don't know quite
where you are so where do you work but
are you okay with all this work uh yeah
I did my multi topics I was just at my
luxurious beach house on the Somali
Riviera Brian beautiful there but he's
very reasonable
all right good don't apologize for it
Mark Steyn thank you so much